hey everyone welcome back to the things
today we're going to explore the
craziest most mind-blowing fix our
theories that will definitely change the
way you see Pixar films from here on out
watch until the end to discover the mega
theory that places all the Pixar movies
on the very same timeline speak hi there
Andy's mom
Pixar theorist John Negroni is a blogger
with a lot of insight into the Pixar
world remember his name because we're
going to circle back to him later on in
this theory he found a connection
between Andy's mom and a certain toy in
the Toy Story movies as John puts it it
all started with a hats he's talking
about the cowboy hats that Andy
frequently wears in the film or should
we say cowgirl hat if you look closely
you'll see that Andy's hat looks more
like Jesse tats
instead of Woody's would you find it
it's the same red hat with white lacing
around the brim as the one that Andy
wears and while there is a white bands
around the crown of Jesse's hat that
element is missing in Andy's but look
closer and you'll see a faded area where
the band used to be we all remember the
heartbreaking story of Jesse's owner
Emily who outgrew her and discarded her
by the side of the road
well Negroni believes that emily was
actually Andy's mom and that she kept
her hat eventually handing it down to
Andy the buuck this Pixar theory is
pretty popular even if it is a bit of a
mind bender apparently Boo is actually a
time-traveling witch from brave allow us
to explain according to mini fan
theories boo misses Sulley so much she
becomes obsessed with finding him so she
grows up to become a witch who uses
magic on doors to travel through time so
she can look for her long-lost furry
friend she winds up going all the way
back to the source of magic the will of
the wisps from brave
that means Boo is the same witch from
brave and she has one goal to find her
kitty who bears a striking resemblance
to a bear that explains why she
disappears whenever she passes through
the door and if you look at her workshop
you'll see a carved piece of wood that
resembles Sulley as the theory goes boo
has traveled all over
the pixar verse leaving clues or easter
eggs and other Pixar movies in the hopes
that she will leave Sulley back into her
loving arms mini fans believe that's the
reason for all of the Easter eggs and
Pixar films they are all a part of booze
quests to be reunited with her monster I
have no idea but it would be really
great if it didn't do it again
Bing bong is a monster who's your
friends who likes to play who's the guy
who made us all sob in our popcorn at
the movies Bing bong we all know that
Bing bong made the ultimate sacrifice in
order to save Riley's joy and inside out
what if it wasn't as big of a sacrifice
as we all believed what if it was just a
memory that vanished and not the actual
character our pal Jon Negroni believes
that Bing bong might actually be from
the monsters ink world and that he was
assigned to Riley to make her laugh
maybe Bing bong became a colleague of
Mike and Sulley
after the restructuring of the company
so when they learned that monsters could
create more energy from laughter than
screams Bing bong became a natural fist
as a new recruit that would mean that
Riley's memories of playing with Bing
bong were real and not just figments of
her imagination if that's the case it
seems like Bing bong was breaking some
rules by following Riley out into her
living room in broad daylight but he's
so adorable who cares
so Riley's laughter could be a part of
the energy that lights up Monstropolis
the truth about Andy's father as it
turns out Woody's history with his human
family could go back a lot farther then
Andy's childhood he online interviewed
Mike Mozart a toy creator who consulted
on the Toy Story films Mozart revealed a
secret that his late friend Toy Story
co-writer doh ramped shared with him
many years ago regarding the backstory
of Andy's father according to this
theory
Andy's dad passed away before Andy's
sister was born due to illness from
childhood polio Andy's father whose name
was also Andy was the original owner of
the classic 1950s toys mr. Potato Head
slinky dog and of course woody that name
written on the bottom of Woody's boot is
actually in his dad's childhood
handwriting it's kind of a long story
but Andy's dad locked these toys in a
trunk in the attic and passed them on to
Andy jr. a
according to Mozart and his dad gave
Andy the key to the trunk he told his
son that there is someone in that box
who is going to be his favorite deputy
and his best friend he told little Andy
that he is going to need a friend so he
wanted him to have the same best friend
that he had as a child we're not crying
you're crying cars replaced humans let's
ride the theory train from sad town some
morbid town with us next one screen
crushed journalist Matt singer
interviewed J Ward the creative director
of cars movies at a press junket for
cars three he asked award where these
cars came from Ward's answer which he
claims as his own theory and has not
been confirmed by Pixar is pretty dark
he said that we are currently living in
a time of autonomous car technology we
literally have driverless cars so we
posed the possibility of a time in the
near future when cars keep getting
smarter and more sophisticated
eventually they may ask why they even
need human beings anymore they may
decide to just get rid of us Ward added
that the cars would take on the
personality of the last person who drove
them
yikes that means is the fix our world
the human race was phased out by cute
big eyed cars suddenly the cars movies
seem more like horror flicks the by and
large take over this huge corporate
conglomerates can be found all over the
Pixar universe by and large or BNL is
the corporation that runs everything you
see in the movie wall-e the BNL
commercial in the film shows a history
of the massive organization the
commercials states that BNL has even
taken over all the world's governments
that means they succeeded in obtaining
complete global dominance you'll see
references to this company in several
Pixar movies if you're paying close
attention
for instance in Toy Story 3 the
batteries in the Buzz Lightyear doll are
from dnl if you follow the timeline of
all the Pixar films the movie up
represents the beginning of the
by-and-large takeover if you look at the
construction equipment that aims to tear
down Carl's house you'll see that they
all have the BNL logo on them
then be now just keeps getting bigger
and bigger until you come to wall-e
where everything has been destroyed the
humans have become these weak blobs with
no planets and no free will
Hey aren't kids movies supposed to be
happy up is an allegory this theory
began with a fans posts back in 2012
reddit user boo bonus kicked everyone
right in the fields with this revelation
according to the redditor Karl's journey
in the movie up may not be real this
user believes that Carl Fredricksen
passed away in his sleep the night he
came home from court with in order to
move out of his beloved home what do I
do now
everything that happens after that night
is an allegory for Carl's journey
through the afterlife while we would
like to believe that you can make a
housefly with a bunch of helium balloons
it's highly unlikely
instead the raising of the house
represents Carl's spirit floating up and
out of his physical form and into the
spiritual world that would make Russell
Carl's guardian angel or spiritual guide
Russell mentions and he is trying to
earn his final badge which can be
likened to an angel's wings another fan
added that Russell could have taken the
form of a child to fulfill Carl and
Ellie's desire to have children
mind blown Nemo is made up as fans have
pointed out in Jules Verne's classic
sci-fi adventure 20,000 Leagues Under
the Sea Nemo is Latin for no one it's
interesting that Pixar chose this name
for their title character why would they
say that Marlin is finding no one
according to fix our fan theories it's
because Nemo is actually a figment of
Marlins imagination but really happened
is that the Barracuda who is responsible
for wiping out Marlins entire family
didn't actually miss that last little
egg the whole tale of this classic movie
follows a grieving father who must come
to grips with losing everyone he loved
people have likened Marlins journey as a
representation of the stages of grief
when Marlin thinks his son survived he
is in a state of pure denial he then
skips right over anger and goes to
bargaining when he won't allow Nemo to
take any risks at school he goes through
various stages of anger and depression
along his journey in the end
see Marlins acceptance when he sends
Nemo to school without any fear
so if you cried enough salt water to
fill the fish tank after this theory
don't worry you're not alone brave if
you follow the time line brave is the
Pixar film set in the earliest time
period in the movie Merida discovers a
mysterious magic that she uses to try
and solve her problems but then her
mother is accidentally turned into a
bear from our previous fan theory we now
know that this magic comes from the boo
witch and is connected to the mysterious
will love the wisps we see animals
behaving like humans as well as
inanimate objects like broomsticks in a
witch's shop the theory states that the
witch experimented on and interbred the
animals which began the human-like
progression of the animals and all
subsequent Pixar films like ratatouille
Finding Nemo up and Monsters Inc
inanimate objects also progressed with
artificial intelligence such as cars and
robots this error of human-like animal
intelligence and artificial intelligence
all began with the witch and brave the
Pixar theory this leads us to an
interesting mega theory that connects
all of the Pixar movies together it was
created by the Pixar theory master John
Negroni remember him from the beginning
of the video now this theory is detailed
and complicated so we're going to just
do a super quick breakdown for you here
the good dinosaur marks the beginning of
this alternate dimension where the
asteroid responsible for dinosaur
extinction misses the earth since these
animals survived they love to have
higher intelligence then the witch from
brave gives life to inanimate objects as
well as human-like qualities two animals
jump to the 1950s and 60s when the
government creates human superheroes
syndromes invention of artificial
intelligence wipes out the supers and
this leads to the beginning of mega
corporation by and large BNL makes toys
as a way to harness and feed off of
human energy fish developed the
abilities Hawk read and speak in
different languages our rat becomes a
famous chef Easter eggs abound in every
movie buzz has B&L batteries he now has
the construction crew that levels Carl's
house and we learned that human emotion
has enough energy to
up a city also bing-bong is a monster
koco's story proves that human memories
also have power B&L takes over the
planet and moved everyone to space cars
take over the world even wall-e bring up
plants down to earth it is planted and
eventually becomes the tree in a bug's
life at the end of Monsters Inc boo
becomes a witch in order to find the
magic that will lead her back to Sulley
she learns how to time travel through
wooden doors she door jumps back in time
to recreate the monster she once loved
whose ancient ancestors were probably
human like bears whoo what do you guys
think of this mega theory do you think
it's possible for all the Pixar movies
to be connected if you agree with
Negroni on this epic mind-bending Pixar
theory leave a bear emoji in the
comments and those really craziest picks
our theories of all time if you got
Pixar movies as much as we do be sure to
subscribe to the things Channel and give
this video a thumbs up thanks for
watching